[Music]
it's been almost 30 years since steven
spielberg's jurassic park immersed us
into the world of dinosaurs
six movies and endless adventurous and
breathtaking hours later
jurassic world dominion is now the
franchise of six part
and fans can hardly wait to finally
admire it on the big screen
still which actors will we see are any
familiar faces returning
and which new dinosaurs will the stars
have to run away from this time
we've dealt with all these questions and
summarized everything you need to know
about the sixth film in this video
so sit back and be amazed at all that's
in store for you
and if you haven't seen the last two
movies or if you can still recall
everything feel free to skip ahead as
now follows a recap of jurassic world
1 and 2. jurassic world picks up 22
years after the opening of the first
park
a new park has opened in the south of
illinois a maglev crane even allows
visitors to ride into the enclosures of
let's say the more peaceful dinosaurs
claire deering portrayed by bryce dallas
howard is the director of the facility
she's tasked with introducing the newest
attraction the indominus rex
he's an artificially created dinosaur
whose jeans are a combination of
many different species to avoid another
disaster the gamekeeper owned grady
embodied by chris pratt
is assigned to inspect the safety of the
enclosure previously
owen was mainly busy training four
velociraptors who accepted him into
their pack
once inside the enclosure the game
keeper discovers that the super dinosaur
is able to hide from the thermal cameras
due to its genetic manipulation
it kills the two technicians
accompanying owen and manages to escape
into the open park after wiping out the
entire security team that was supposed
to recapture him the visitors are
evacuated together with owen claire sets
out to find her visiting nephews
leaving the indominus with a new target
he destroys the paterasaurus enclosure
causing them to escape into the wild and
also crashing the owner's helicopter
while the now free dinosaurs attack the
other visitors the military takes
command
of the island and orders the
velociraptors to be used against the
monster
claire decides to release the
tyrannosaurus for support and a
ferocious battle erupts between the two
giants
and the raptor's alpha leader blue
together they push him into the water
enclosure where the huge mossosaurus
appears and drags the indominus
into the depths as last seen the t-rex
is seen facing the abandoned park with a
loud roar
in the second part mankind has to make
an important decision
the volcano on illinois is about to
erupt which could once again
wipe out the dinosaur species even
though the southerners decided against
saving them
the heroes of part one dared to go on a
rescue mission
with the help of benjamin lockwood who
was a business partner of john hammond
they fly to the island to save as many
dinosaurs as possible
once on the island they manage to locate
blue however
when they try to contact her the true
intentions of the new companions come to
light
as they sedate the raptor as well as
owen the raptor
whisperer is left to die and only
awakens when the volcano erupts
he and claire barely escape from the
eruption are forced to watch as numerous
dinosaurs are taken away by the poachers
onto his ship
as things turn out they are taken to the
lockwood's estate to be auctioned off
there they meet a new super dinosaur the
indoraptor
whose attacks can be controlled with a
laser targeting system
in order to stir up chaos claire and
owen free the other dinosaurs
meanwhile the indoraptor is also able to
free itself and is now preying on people
while fleeing from the predator they
meet lockwood's granddaughter maisie who
turns out to be a clone of his daughter
who died young
blue also succeeds in freeing herself
and together with own she
takes up the fight against the
indoraptor
in the final battle the two raptors fall
through the roof of the building
and the super dinosaurs impaled on the
fossil skull
of a triceratops through a hole in the
hydrogen cyanide tank poisonous gas
leaks out which is about to kill all of
the trapped dinosaurs
as a result the heroes decide to release
them into the wild
they decided to do this mainly because
macy herself says she's a genetic
experiment and is allowed to live on
freely
at the last scene the t-rex and the line
are seen roaring at each other in a zoo
the biggest team change was probably on
the director's chair
colin trevorov is coming back he already
directed part 1 but gave up the chair in
favor for spaniard j.a biona and fallen
kingdom
after all he was never completely gone
from the franchise but continued to
contribute as a producer and
screenwriter
the script is written by emily
carmichael and derek connolly
carmichael's work is well known from
pacific rim uprising while derry conley
has already worked on the first two
movies
the film has a budget of 165 million us
dollars which is 5 million less than
part 2.
filming began in february 2020 and had
to be interrupted after less than a
month due to the ongoing situation
by the end of november they were
fortunately able to wrap up
though this was only possible under the
strictest conditions of around
40 000 rapid deaths and additional costs
of
9 million dollars due to the longer
shooting time the expected film release
has been pushed back to june 10th
2022 exactly four years after part two
of course we can't promise when to
expect the first trailer exactly
but you can probably expect it at the
end of this year
once the trailer drops you'll be able to
find it either on our channel or
on our website a few details about the
plot have already leaked out
for instance the dinosaurs will not
rampage as many have speculated
so there will be no dinosaur human war
but fans can expect a science thriller
according to trevorov
in addition the concept of genetically
modified super dinosaurs is abandoned
and the paleontological path is being
taken
once again this is surely also a reason
why the 90s stars have been recalled or
will have a bigger role to play
the director says the film will focus on
ethical and scientific issues and how to
reconcile them
jeff goldblum recently even hinted that
the effects of the ongoing pandemic will
find their subject matter
in the film while the velociraptors and
the tyrannosaurus rex will certainly get
one or two scenes in the movie again
pictures from the set have already
surfaced that show the nasty
consognatus from the lost world the cute
looking little dinosaurs may seem
adorable but as we know from jurassic
park 2
they are vicious killers moreover images
surfaced on twitter showing another
carnivore namely the pyroraptor
historically the lizard hit dinosaur
lived in what is now provence france
this time we're more likely to see it in
the united states though
further details are not yet known and
will only be revealed with the release
of the first trailer
but it's already clear that with the
third part of the story the saga will
come to an end
john traverov even goes so far as to say
in an interview that if you watch all
six jurassic park films at once
it'll look like a career and story
although there will be more movies in
the future
those will then shed light on a new
story
in addition to raptor trying to own
grady the tough clear daring will of
course
also take a leading role both are played
as expected by marvel star chris pratt
and bryce dallas howard
that said five other familiar faces from
the jurassic world series will be back
as well the jittery systems analyst
franklin webb will support our heroes in
their new adventure
like before also part of the team is his
intelligent colleague dr
zia rodriguez both had already played a
significant role in the second part to
save the dinosaurs from the demise
as before they're embodied by justice
smith and daniela pineda
for both of them jurassic world fallen
kingdom was their first major role in
hollywood isabella sermon will also make
another appearance as
macy lockwood it'll certainly be
interesting to see what role the cologne
of the deceased billionaire's daughter
will play
in the end it was mainly her moral will
that determined the release of the
dinosaurs into the wild
however the dinosaur experts will also
receive support from characters of the
2015 movie
with barry zomban the second raptor
trainer from jurassic world returns to
the series
he's personified by french actor omasai
he's a good friend of own and will as
one can only assume
join him in the search for the escaped
raptor blue the final character from
jurassic world to return to the dinosaur
adventure is lori cruthers
he worked as a safety engineer in the
control room of the park until the
tragedy happened
and ended up being the hero who didn't
want to leave his position until the
very
end so far it is unknown what he did
after the incident on the island
but this is certainly information which
the new film will provide us with
once again you will be played by new
girl star jake johnson
fans of the 90 series can rejoice
because not only will chaos theorist dr
ian malcolm who already had a small role
in the fallen kingdom be seen again
but the protagonist drawing grand and dr
ellie settler
will also be back on the team
for both it's their first appearance
since 2001's jurassic park 3.
and the renowned paleontologist and
paleobotanist are sure to be highly
sought after now that dinosaurs
are making their way across the united
states
in an interview director colin trevor
also said that the roles of the three
former stars should not be
underestimated
especially if you want to establish a
connection between all the movies
so fans can look forward to the trio
being given quite a bit of screen time
in malcolm will of course be played by
jeff goldblum once again along with the
two scientists being cast with simneil
and laura dern
besides the three main actors of the
first trilogy bd wong is also present as
the genetic engineer dr
henry wu who like goldblum already
appeared in the otherworld movies
dodgeland will also play a role for the
first time since part one
wait dodges don't you ask well rightly
so he'll probably be remembered by
very few people it was him who in the
first minutes of jurassic park gave
dennis nedry the shaving cream cannon
with
witch to steal a dinosaur embryos from
elon nublar
we can only speculate how the character
will translate into the new film since
he didn't make any further appearances
other than in this particular scene he
is the only one who has been recast as
well
this time around dungeon has been played
by campbell scott instead of cameron
thor
as he was in 1993 the latter was
actually sentenced to six years in
prison in 2016
for sexually harassing minors
with the wonderwise and mamadou fee the
starcast will be further
expanded unfortunately nothing about
their roles has been announced so far
and the revival of previous stars also
raises questions about how big their
roles will be
however prior talks spoke of a leading
role but whether they will be done so
friends or enemies
remains open anyhow we are excited and
we are looking forward to the two
newcomers
this like man scott hayes are also part
of the cast but will probably get a
small role
while lagman is known for tv series
hayes start and venom and zeroville in
recent years
well now you should be up to date with
the new jurassic world despite the fact
that it'll still take a little while
until we can admire it in theaters
what are you most looking forward to in
the movie is there a dinosaur
we still know about and that you'd like
to see on the big screen
let us know in the comments and if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up
[Music]
you